Larry is with us in Rapid City South
Dakota hi Larry
how are you I'm doing fine David thanks
for taking my call it says X ray employ
Road sure what's up the other day I was
developing and all our insurance and
most of my insurance I kind of figured
it out as far as levels and stuff like
that but I'm kind of struggling on what
to do with our personal liability
insurance because we got that
million-dollar policy way back when when
when we were I would say knee deep or
neck deep in debt because my wife's a
doc and now I just kind of kind of
looked at our balance sheet so to speak
and much to my surprise I discovered
where a millionaire and I'm just kind of
wondering if if we're under covered
liability our policy is 1 million most
are in retirement investments is like
1.2 our real estate is just to save
under a million because we have a couple
different properties one of them this
kind of a kind of a rental I mean it we
rent it because it's like our second
home that it's kind of a vacation
program but it's you know it's not
official rental property as such I'm not
talking about talking about a little bit
but let me interrupt you not talking
about her being a doc and not talking
about any kind of liability about that
but just general liability meaning like
a car insurance and homeowners insurance
and rental property insurance and so
forth a liability umbrella policy is
probably what you have that's the extra
million that you've got you know right
you know do you do have enough net worth
and she does have doc after her name
those two things put a target on your
but if somebody slips and falls on a
rental property and they're gone they're
gone I got go I think they're killed
myself over here you know and you know
you have to go through all that crap so
yeah is the rental properties are they
their personal use some and some sound
like a resort property rented some and
live ISM yeah we always say we probably
use it a couple months out of the year
but it's not our rental okay so in and
then like when we're not there we'll
take advantage of the summertime and and
rent it you know I think we have the
right approach on that the only question
I've got about that is is that you may
want to slip that into an LLC if you
haven't and so it's standalone and if
something happened on that property that
LLC if it's properly documented and you
run the business as an LLC then if
something happened in that property
alone then that's the most they could
sue you for is that and so that's a
little bit of risk management I don't
put more than five million dollars for
the real estate in one LLC like if I've
got you know five six seven houses or
something I get I get it that's one LLC
and then I'll start another one so
that's the most they could get after if
they wanted to come after that the
building I'm sitting in is worth about
probably 15 or 20 million something like
that it's it's own separate LLC so if
I've got a big piece of real estate I
have a separate LLC for each of those
and so that limits the size of the
target from being the whole portfolio
down to individual things because those
LLC's are conducted properly they're
standalone businesses and you can only
sue for the assets of that business if
you are harmed at that location
and so that that's a little bit of risk
management and then the other thing it
sounds like your net worth north of 4
million and so you know you may want to
look at bumping that to 5 million that
liability umbrella I carry 10 and you
can you can go from a million to 5
million I don't remember what that cost
a million is usually about two hundred a
year it'll probably be probably three
times that probably less than thousand
dollars a year for for a five million
dollar and you know it's just
inexpensive insurance and you work so
hard and so many hours and so much
diligence to build up this ass
that base that you don't want one
singular catastrophic event to destroy
the whole thing and that's what the
liability policy is it's the it's the
cheapest of all insurance it's the best
buy and all kinds of insurance is the
best buy I mean just I mean you can't
give five million of anything for that
kind of money you know in anything else
so you know price it with your insurance
broker and let them shop around there's
a lot of people sell a million dollars
and there's a few that sell five intense
you want to get over ten it starts
getting a little hairy but I just do
other things for risk management in
addition to the ten so you know try to
set your properties apart and separate
things to make the target smaller if
someone decide they want to be let it
just one to litigate on you and and
carry your liability insurance so yeah I
find me I'm going to shop that and you
look at it and based on the price you
get quoted if you think it's worth that
to transfer that risk it probably is hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you